[Musique]
on aura tous bienvenue sur le plateau de
la grande interview
un plateau qui s'est installée de façon
exceptionnelle dans le cadre du forum
économique de saint-pétersbourg qui a
réouvert ses portes après une année de
fermeture liée bien sûr à la crise du
comique beaucoup de monde cette année
pour en parler emmanuel quidet président
de la chambre de commerce franco russe
ici a réussi à moscou ou plutôt à vous
êtes hassan massoudy et vous avez fait
le déplacement c'est pas votre premier
forum vous en avez fait combien de roms
c'est mon deuxième france 12e et donc je
suis dit de nombreuses fois
comment vous jugez l'état d'esprit
comment vous jugez la citation nous
sommes en plein conte vivre dans un
climat politique est pas fameux fameux
alors qu'il ya beaucoup de monde là
on ne savait pas combien de personnes à
venir il y a deux ans il ya eu quinze
mille participants
aujourd'hui j'ai encore du mal à mende
contre comme un participant il ya mais
il y en a plusieurs milliers et malgré
des tensions politiques qui sont
effectivement forte comme vous le
rappeliez mais la france est un grand
investisseur et la france est très
présente aujourd'hui aux formes de
sainte-thérèse du nord
la chambre de commerce
franco russe
qui donc a installé ici c'est une
organisation une initiative privée
affilié au réseau des chambres de
commerce international et mais c'est une
organisation privée qui vit avec les
cotisations de ses membres
exactement ce qui vous donne une très
grande liberté par rapport à l'état par
rapport à l'administration je parle bien
sûr de l'état français de
l'administration française
combien de divisions comme on disait
autrefois du vatican vous et combien
d'entreprises adhérentes ici il ya 400
plus de 400 entreprises membres de la
chambre de commerce nous sommes une
chambre de commerce franco russe donc
nous avons deux tiers de membres
français un tiers de membres russes mais
nous avons aussi ce qu'on appelle un
conseil économique qui regroupe les
principaux investisseurs français et
leurs partenaires en russie et ce
conseil économique eco prisé par patrick
guyanais le le président de total energy
maintenant et guennadi timchenko qui est
son partenaire dans novatek en russie et
avec ce conseil économique nous pouvons
avoir accès à toutes les autorités
russes et françaises pour l'intérêt de
nos membres et l'intérêt et améliorer ma
d'investissement russe votre fonction
c'était évidemment de permettre la
liaison entre les entreprises et le
marché local entre les entreprises et
les partenaires locaux bien cela c'était
l'une de nos fonctions que vous êtes
prestataires de services aussi on est
prestataire de services vous parlez du
fonctionne à 100 ma première fonctionne
la chambre c'est de fédérer la
communauté d'affaires française que nous
ont comme nous sommes une chambre
d'affaires une chambre de commerce
franco russe ben nous le faisons avec
nos amis russes de façon à mettre les
gens en contact mais avec le conseil
économique et le think tank que nous
avons créé l'observatoire franco russe
qui fait des analyses politiques
économiques culturelles sur la russie
nous avons créé un outil qui nous permet
d'avoir accès aux plus hautes autorités
de l'état français de l'état russe et
qui nous permet d'améliorer le climat
d'investissement aussi tout temps
tout en privilégiant les relations
économiques franco-russes c'est pas la
une des plus et pas la plus grosse
chambre de commerce internationale
française 1 mais déjà parmi les plus
gros seins alors comment vous sentez le
climat si l'on peut parler d'un climat
de la préco vide
est ce que vous sentez la façon dont les
gens dont les entreprises vont se
redresser vont rebondir
elles vont bondir d'abord spécifiquement
sur la france la france est un
investisseur extrêmement important aussi
parce que nous sommes le second
investisseur en cumulé dans le pays
nous sommes le premier employeur
étranger et nous avons plus de 1200
entreprises françaises présentes en
russie
ce qui veut donc dire à peu près toutes
les entreprises du cac 40 à l'exception
de trois ou quatre mais beaucoup de
peine
donc les entreprises sont extrêmement
présente et active et surtout aucune
entreprise n'a quitté la russie depuis
la crise de crédit de 2013
donc les français sont là et continuent
à investir et investissent massivement
ce qui explique notre bonne position
deux secondes investisseurs alors on
sait ce que la russie nous nous sommes
principalement du gaz principalement du
pétrole
on sait moins ce que les entreprises
françaises viennent faire ici mais comme
vous êtes quasiment toutes les
entreprises du cac 40 vous pouvez
imaginer que nous sommes présents dans
énormément de secteurs bien évidemment
avec total énergie dans le gaz
puisqu'ils ont investi dans un grand
champ de gaz de duke et passion mais la
pharmacie renault est très présent le
groupe auchan est le premier employeur
étranger en russie
le
[Musique]
saint gobain l'air liquide enfin nous
sommes présents dont énormément de
secteurs de l'industrie et bien
évidemment accompagné par les pme qui
sont avec elle et qui l accompagne leur
développement à venir les relations les
flux entre la france et la russie sont
importants parce que là non plus on
n'est ni le premier fournisseur ni le
premier client de la russie
les relations commerciales que la russie
avec la chine sont en volume beaucoup
plus important c'est assez intéressant à
noter c'est que si vous voyez avant
la crise du crédit yens l'union
européenne était le premier
et de loin le
vraiment le le premier pays où fin de
zone avec lequel la comelle là aussi
comme hershey s'étaient 55% et la chine
était quasiment inexistante aujourd'hui
la chine représente plus de 20% des
commerces avec la russie et l'union
européenne est descendue à 40%
donc oui la chine est extrêmement
importante aujourd'hui en commerce pas
en investissement ils sont peu présents
d'investissement alors vous parlez du
recul relatif de l'europe sur le marché
russe
comment vous l'expliquez en dehors de la
montée en puissance de la de la chine
les deux sont liés bien sûr mais vous
allez comprendre comment elles mêmes
il ya quand même une responsabilité des
européens mais j'ai besoin de voir
pourquoi les deux sont liés c'est que on
explique mme quasiment exclusivement par
la mise en place des sanctions des
sanctions économiques des sanctions
économiques ont été créés pour bien
évidemment faire mal à la russie a fait
bien là le seul procédé au lendemain de
l'affairé crânienne lendemain d'affaires
reculer seul problème ce que nous avions
dit à l'époque méfions-nous elles
peuvent se retourner contre nous et
c'est exactement ce qui s'est passé donc
elles ont affaibli les relations entre
l'union européenne et la russie mais
entre la russie l'union c'est bien que
on a eu une baisse grosso modo de 20% de
notre assez immédiate de notre courant
d'importation d'exportation
et eux
et il a bien fallu remplacer tout ce que
nous délivrer au plus à la russie et qui
l'a remplacé mais pas que la chine met
en grande partie l'achat la chine a pris
là où la beauté la chine est dû aux
sanctions européennes a donc ses
sanctions économiques contre laquelle
nous nous opposons toujours rue pour
effet de mettre en avant la russie et au
détriment de leurs lieux robben et la
france en particulier
monsieur le président car il ya quand
même un problème d'équilibré global
parce que on vit ou actuellement sous la
menace de nouvelles sanctions
puisque les européens les américains
n'ont pas caché leur mécontentement
notamment après la sphère de l'avion
biélorusse et ses nouvelles fonctions
dont on parle serait éventuellement une
exclusion du système de paiement
international ce qui mettrait à mal
l'économie russe mais ce qui mettrait
aussi à mal l'économie européenne une
certaine façon la sp side notre analyse
celle là est bien évidemment je n'y
crois pas
parce que ça causerait épiquement des
dommages à tout le monde et je ne crois
pas qu'il puisse faire sortir la russie
du service du siècle du système ce choix
du système swift
de toute façon s'il le faisait il faut
bien voir que il y a dix ans les russes
n'étaient pas prêts aujourd'hui le sont
ils ont remplacé le système swift
donc ils peuvent tout à fait notamment
avec la chine et avec notre pays du
brics les russes peuvent monter un
système des légions déjà montée finale à
cacher donc il pourrait tout à fait
compensé
aujourd'hui je vais pas vous dire que ça
serait bien pour eux mais est il ne
serait pas du tout dans la situation
dans des eaux où il n'avait rien d'un an
maintenant ils ont un autre système qui
peut le remplacer
donc j'avais pas la raison pour laquelle
en troll je pense pas non plus que
l'union européenne leur est en place et
les sanctions européennes aussi
dommageable soit elles sont beaucoup
moins genre de truc que les socios
américaine
ce que les sommets et leurs peines sont
très précises on les connaît elle donc
pas vraiment varié depuis 2014 et elles
sont respectées bien évidemment par
toutes les entreprises européennes
investissant aussi mais on sait on les
connaît et on peut on voit ce qu'on peut
faire une affaire les sanctions
américaines sont beaucoup plus
inquiétante parce que elles sont basées
justement sur l'incertitude
donc elle peut venir à tout moment sans
qu'on sache pourquoi
et son sens warning donc le
ce sont des sanctions américaines qui
sont les plus dangereuses porno il ya
certains industriels français qui se
cache pas pour expliquer en privé que
nous avons quand même tendance avec le
jouet des américains dans les rapports
avec la russie
c'est à dire que nous sommes à leur
mercie quelque part sans savoir
exactement
pour quel corps dans quel camp tomber ou
s'il faut tomber dans un camp nous
sommes à la fois tenu par notre fidélité
à l'otan au parapluie américain
mais nous sommes aussi tenté de jouer la
complémentarité géographique de
proximité c'est une analyse politique
tout à fait crédible
ce que je vois en tant que président de
chambre de commerce et que les sanctions
économiques américaines qui sont extra
territorial ce que ne sont pas des
sanctions européennes évidemment avec
cet extra territorialité des lois et 103
le tournis le droit que les impurs et
doit d'exactement qui travaillerait en
dollar avec un l'on connaît à l'heure ni
statistique reconnaît l'artiste à la
merci pascal à bercy dans n'iront par
exemple c'est très clair c'est des plats
grand et il n'y a pas un autre problème
est là ça vous concerne directement de
concurrence à l'intérieur de l'europe un
manque de coordination
il ya un léger elle encore dimension
également bien évidemment il ya un léger
manque de coordination ça ne leur allait
alléger mais mais on arrive néanmoins a
parlé à nos amis allemands et on arrive
quand même malgré les concurrences enfin
la concorde joue à plein et cela marche
bien évidemment il ya une légère
différence d'interprétation des
sanctions selon que vous êtes allemands
ou français
les français sont un petit peu plus
orthodoxes si je puis m'exprimer ainsi
que les allemands sur l'interprétation
des sanctions économiques mais mais mais
c'est pas un problème majeur c'est pas
le problème majeur des sanctionnés et
vous ne pensez pas que l'allemagne poche
en gala merkel tout changer aussi de
l'attitude alors elle peut mais alors
franchement je ne sais pas qui va être
élu après angela merkel ainsi on parle
de la candidate verte
on parle aussi la cd où ça surement plus
importante elle sera elle sera très
forte
mais si c'est le candidat de la cdo qui
l'emportent ce sera beaucoup plus
modérée non franchement il faut qu'on
attende le mois de septembre pour voir
évitement qui va gagner
[Musique]
comment est ce que vous percevez les
russes par rapport à cette question-là
de l'environnement qui crée concernés
quitterait concernant pour les européens
mais vous venez on vient de finir de
terminer une table-ronde franco-russe
dans lequel vous aviez monsieur pouyanne
est monsieur tricoire monsieur d enfin
tous les présidents de ces grandes
banques de ces grandes sociétés
françaises et en fait c'est tout le
terme qu'on a abordé est en fait via un
rapprochement absolument fulgurant entre
la france et la russie sur cette âme de
décarbonisation de transportation
sur de médicalisation la liquidité l'art
de digitalisation et sur justement tous
ces termes de ces thèmes du futur
candidat du futur c'est un futur
extrêmement proches
pour l'amélioration des
des désaccords de paris pour les
libertés en russie
vous me dites la russie est très
concerné la réussite va coopérer alors
que le coeur de son activité si qu elles
le pétrole et le gaz pas son intérêt
c'est de vendre du pétrole sont
intéressés d'or du gaz et au prix le
plus cher
oui non parce que de toute façon il va y
avoir un changement d'énergie donc là
aussi c'est ici il est amorcée bien
évidemment et la russie doivent faire
face et elle est amorcée comment vous
voyez très bien en gaz steg aujourd'hui
la russie des carbones le gaz et le dé
carbone extrêmement rapidement beaucoup
plus rapidement qu aux etats unis
donc vous avez un gaz rossi qui est
beaucoup plus vert plus attractif en
partie pour le tout le gaz liquéfié
alors c'est pas encore tout le gaz livré
mais c'est ce qu'ils sont en train de
mettre en place jusque là la france est
un rôle majeur à jouer
vous le voyez pour le gaz c'est et vous
le voyez pour toutes les nouvelles
énergies à l'hydrogène
les russes sont viennent de passer à un
contre un entre rossato mais edf entre
les chemins de fer russes et la sncf
entre gazprom et mj donc le l'hydrogène
et l'ammoniac sont de sources d'énergie
verte extrêmement importante pour le
futur
et une fois encore croire du futur un
futur très proche sur lesquels les
russes et les français sont tout à fait
en accord qu'elle est l'attractivité que
vous mettez en avant pour les produits
français et pour les entreprises
françaises
la taille de la russie la russie tap les
marchés ben oui c'est un pays de 147
millions d'habitants et qui est un
pouvoir
lâchez la bande ans oui mais pas plus
bas que l'occident que
le bac l'accident mais mais loin d'être
négligeable d'ailleurs la suite vous
promener dans les versions pour voir
toutes les voitures européennes que vous
pouvez y trouver y compris françaises
renault détient 35% du marché de
l'automobile russe donc
donc vous avez un pouvoir d'achat
beaucoup plus important qu'on ne le
pense est un marché important est à nos
portes et surtout la traction elle est
culturelle terre que je ne pense pas
qu'ils payent plus proche pour nos amis
russes que la france parce que
culturellement nous sommes d'identiques
nous avons les mêmes demandes de noms
mais je pourrais je pourrais vous en
parler pour notre jeu
non nous avons la même façon de penser
et c'est très important parce que nous
réagissions de la même façon et je le
vois dans les affaires tout le temps
c'est beaucoup plus simple pour des rues
de faire des affaires avec des français
que avec
les pays voisins qu'est-ce qui est
difficile ici vous avez maj il ya un a
priori à bâle image quand vous êtes à
l'extérieur entendu à l'extérieur bien
évidemment l'image de la russie et
tapent sur des affichettes entreprises
ici sont d'une prudence quand il s'agit
de parler de la russie mais qu'ils
savent qu'ils sont décotés enfants sans
fin mais vous êtes c'est intéressant on
avait fait un sondage il ya quelques
années il est vrai qu'on ne refasse là
vous aviez on avait demandé aux
entreprises françaises présentes en
russie
s'ils voulaient investir t 98% des
entreprises présentes en russie voulait
réinvestir
on avait posé la même question des
entreprises françaises qui n'étaient pas
aussi dicté 50% voleurs venir dire
qu'une fois qu'ils soient ici
s'aperçoivent que non seulement il ya
marché qu'on ait fait des affaires
relativement facilement ya des
difficultés mais mais dites moi un pays
où il n'ya pas de difficulté et je
vivais immédiatement et la taille du
marché aux portes de la france est
vraiment important donc
donc oui oui dans lequel vous venir
d'ailleurs les entreprises françaises
sont présentes ici pas par hasard 2.222
points pour terminer le premier porte
sur le digital
on n'a pas le sentiment que ce soit une
un axe majeur de préoccupations au
niveau des investissements et que
finalement côté russe comme côté
européen on a laissé faire les gaffes à
et puis c'est pas plus mal
alors qu'est ce que c'est du moins le
sentiment qui nous permettrait à tort
parce que c'est me voir moscou où
j'habite et c'est la même chose à saint
pétersbourg mais moscou y habitent
beaucoup plus déduites alizés que paris
mais nettement plus c'est à dire que
lorsqu'ils ont mis en place les parts m
il était immédiatement sur vos
téléphones avec du avec du matériel du
logiciel américain alors on peut avoir
du matériel ou de logiciels américain
mais attention ils ont développé ils ont
développé leur gaffard ils ont développé
hyundai qu ce qui est leur google a
acquis extrêmement puissante
vous avez tous viande ex taxi index
it takes voilà c'est un outil
extrêmement puissant ayant maquillé
leurs technologies qui étaient eux ils
sont c'est le seul pays au monde avec la
chine à être autonome des russes en la
matière donc non la digitalisation
quelque chose de très important y
compris dans les entreprises à
l'intérieur des recettes de fabrication
de relation client actuellement et vous
vous le voyez dans le système bancaire
qui est très digitalisées vous le voyez
dans les grandes entreprises russes qui
accélère la digitalisation une vitesse
absolument impressionnante
donc oui la digitalisation est un vrai
sujet ici et ils ne sont pas du tout en
retard ils ont des chercheurs donc et on
en parlait ce matin dans nos tables
franco russe ils sont aidés français
sont là justement pour soutenir et aider
les entreprises russes 2e dernier point
adoption malheureusement qu'on a on
arrête des missions le la santé le
secteur de la santé il ya des
entreprises de santé qui viennent
françaises qui sont qui sont présentes
dans votre verre que la déjà vous avez
écrit sanofi servier
j'en oublie mais pas beaucoup de
laboratoires français sont présents en
utilisant des usines un ca bien une
usine sanofi en usine
donc oui sur l'art alors l'actualité est
évidemment braqués sur le vaccin avec
cette difficulté que que les russes dont
les ruches se plaignent c'est à dire
d'un possibilité d'être d'avoir
l'agrément européen
ça vous paraît
politique essentiellement politique ou
ça vous paraît également technique alors
technique je ne comprendrais pas
politique on va voir si j'ai bien
compris doivent dire en juin et doivent
donner leur accord ou non donc si jamais
il refuse
oui il y aura certainement un aspect
politique et mais là on va le voir plus
c'est sur le pass sanitaire parce que si
en admettant qu'ils refusent l'accès du
spoutnik 1 union européenne c'est une
chose s'il le refuse aussi sur le patio
sanitaire oui là ça sera purement
politique
je signale que la grèce l'a autorisée
vous pouvez venir ici je ne sais pas
mais messi l'union européenne leur fusée
sur son pas sanitaires sont absurdes
le fast food nique et quand même reconnu
dans beaucoup de pays à travers le monde
et les russes sont loin d'être
incompétent en la matière donc oui ça on
va le savoir
début juin on va le savoir incessamment
sous peu
on doit le vaccin pour les russes c'est
aussi une arme redoutable en matière
d'exportations parce qu ils prennent les
marchés à l'étranger qui pourraient
coûter sa salle l'est pour les
américains salaires évidemment pas par
l'union européenne qui n'a pas de vaccin
mais mais qu'un dit thierry breton
l'autre jour
au personnel le commissaire français à
qui s'occupe d'ailleurs de s'occupe du
justement de ça et il a rencontré les
personnes qui étaient dans l'avion
arrêté par la biélorussie qu'est ce
qu'il a dit il a dit qu'il ne
délivrerait pas de vaccin européen à la
biélorussie si jamais libéré par
aux journalistes qui étaient enfermés
c'est pas utiliser les vaccins à des
fins politiques
donc même l'union européenne le fait
donc donc dire que la france et l'union
et la russie le fait oui bien sûr et de
il je peux pas vous dire qu'ils ne font
pas mais tout le monde le frère et ma
belle idée merci beaucoup je travaille
je vous en prie le président de la
chambre de commerce franco russe à
moscou
cette émission est terminée vous la
retrouver
en replay vous voulez retrouver sur les
réseaux sociaux il a retrouvé aussi bien
sûr sur le site internet
france - tb voilà à très bientôt
[Musique]